you know my favorite movies are movies
that are funny and dramatic so
you know in my head their their stories
but i find everything in life to be
kind of humorous
no matter how awful uh and that's you
know i love movies like terms of
endearment and
diner and all of the you know the billy
wilder movies and the hal ashby movies
so
to me
it would be weird if there weren't jokes
you know when i see a movie that has no
jokes i always think there's something
wrong
you know it just feels weird where are
the jokes
in uh well every time i do an example of
that it comes out wrong
oh now you got something it was like put
name of tragic movie here with no jokes
but but i do think there should be uh
you know jokes and everything it's so
much fun for an actor um i think we all
have the most fun getting to work with
jive in rehearsals it gets very
collaborative
and
i try to you know
discover you know the scenes through uh
a process that is sitting with the
actors talking through doing another
draft doing another rehearsal i mean
i'll start that process six months
before the shoot begins you know we
usually start out reading that what's on
the page and and then we he makes us
feel like we have freedom to
experiment you know i have what i want
to do but i also have you know 20 other
little ideas that we came up with that
there wasn't room for in the script but
on the day i will shoot them and then at
the end we'll do a take or two where we
where we play it's it's uh
like the scene with melissa at the end
most of that we came up with during
rehearsals or we were kind of screaming
out lines and things and it's kind of
edited to
seem like a stream of consciousness note
that i never once saw judd get angry or
frustrated which is really unique um as
far as directors go especially ones that
are dealing with larger budget movies
because they're under a lot of stress
and a lot of pressure
daily to get the dailies out for people
to watch and approve and for the studio
to be happy with and i never saw him get
frustrated which is great do you just
take it out on like your kids at home
after you go
one of the main things we wondered when
we uh made the film and first screened
it for people was
you know would people
think about uh you know ben and allison
and or not and uh
you know from the very first screening
there was just so few questions about
them that we felt that we had succeeded
in telling a story that stood on its own
two feet and people were just so
interested in what was going on in this
marriage that you know those questions
didn't come up and it was a that was a
gratifying moment and there are some
things that judd will shoot
like he'll shoot an idea that sometimes
will go on the first part of the movie
sometimes it'll go in the middle part of
the movie sometimes go at the end of the
movie and it'll be about just literally
figuring out that's an idea of something
i want to say now where does it
structurally work dramatically the best
in in the movie and so and so now when
we get to the cutting room then it's
really about shaping this amorphous
stuff that that that we've got on the
day and making it really be real and
funny and and
and and and live in in its own way
however the director works
i basically get the same thing if it's
somebody who likes to do lots of takes
i do lots of versions if it's somebody
who has one very clear set idea you know
early on
uh if you work with animators they want
to look at every little clarinet part
for a year and move it
a millimeter one way or another uh just
because that's their way of
you know working period
so in this case it's pretty much i don't
know lay 10 options on the table for you
you'll play with them you'll look at him
eventually he'll point at one we go into
like kind of mode like we're making a
movie now so we can't have feelings for
a few months
and uh
don't bring up that thing that we're mad
about because we got to shoot tomorrow
and what if that starts the whole thing
so we kind of switch gears uh during
that period but uh it was really fun and
it was like a way to have a conversation
with each other
through the characters we have arguments
through
debbie through pitching lines so if i
pitch something for pete it's usually
something i want to say to her and he's
afraid to say yeah
don't you think that maybe we should put
something in about
how debbie's being controlling at this
time
and then she'll say but maybe peach
should admit he's a dick
and then we're having this like two-year
coded debate that's a triumph yeah
but i'm very healthy though
we learn nothing from it that's the
weird
part from it